bravi ragazzi che sono io sono
parcheggiati siamo tornati sul gioco
quello di carte briscola come 1111
quello che mette le carte di quello che
fai quello che li qui vince pietro
vincere l'ultima volta vinto solo pietro
oggi speriamo che io ero tema era via ix
e vera vita no perché nella mia testa
c'è solo lui che vince capito perché io
non ce l'ho con te se vinci va bene
gioco lui nostro braille ma dov'è mio po
quando serve ma l'inizio
va bene sia i signori e grazie gioco si
inizia col botto ma veramente si poteva
fare questa cosa non lo sapevo neanche
cosa potesse vantare
c'è quindi se c'è un più 2 ma dai ma
light live ailes dipende cosa piccolo
ciao piccolo si va ai suo piccolo
ragazzi o una partita faccio in questa
visione se vinco subito vera da via fara
giocare non posso giocare come non farlo
giocare aiuto tutte le partite hai rotto
dai ragazzi mi cambiati i colori però
che già gli 82 chiaro dalla loro carica
watt che a porta proprio quello poi
preso dai colori dai va bene va bene nei
filari di me stesso contesto sbagliato e
non altro astro non è per niente non ce
l'ha non c'era
non mettiamo niente perché no no 3
questione se è arrivata per prima ma che
curò ma vai vai celo celo celo buono
buono
vai astro per cambiate no ora a me serve
questo colori può quindi a prescindere
dalla cambiarlo brutto allora sì ma c'è
la sfida
no ho sbagliato non abbiamo bisogno ho
preso ho preso un po di carte ragazzi ho
sbagliato abbandono anche a me tanto
alla fine
a monte la modalità sfida chi se ne
frega quindi tu cos'è come funziona
stava lì tavolo high speed allora che
seduta più quattro io posso contest arte
lo ok
cosa vuol dire ti contesto è vero se
potevi giocare altre altre carte al
posto del più 4 e potete giocare solo
più 4 per scorse cartello è ok non
mettere quello che stai per pensare e
questo quello mondovì mentre guarda
perché quello che cita è attivato per
per avere sempre le carote quanto scrive
by pesca un po dai 5 ai per la società
ma coi due che ultima volta mi chiamano
fiscante 86 dai ragazzi ora prendi
esempio da leo 21 piace 2 karting bello
bellissimo utile allora non mettere
giallo che ne avrà tutte gialle edizione
maledizione ma io l'ho fatto con queste
carte cosa cosa che la mamma ha fatto
queste carte comunale mamma mia quanto
fate quanto migliore non resta c anche
non lo so mi han o ti ammazzo che non
quindi un ottimo iron di ossimo allora
quest'altro foro praticato nei soldi
pesca pesca no 123 questa interessante
questi signori non gioca più con noi lo
mette perché aggiornamenti azzurro bravo
proprio per questo giallo però andata
bene soda tonico una corretta
ecco una opere da toni ci deve essere un
casino è vero ha vinto non ha violato la
carità
ma attenzione la corregge lui ma ecco
eccoli gli strascichi
no ragazzi rode stesso molto grazie sono
soddisfatto sì e 272 di picco e se
promesso è rialziste doveva avere va
bene forme che non si avevano vedi che
faccio la chiamo ciao guarda la faccia
da killer incredibile non contestare le
procure ma noi ce le ha
a un 5 verde e un blocco rosso si
sacrifica per il pd tredici canti ancora
una vasta e io ho un 5 in mano porco
demonio non è vero è sicuro però non
posso mettere perché sono io ho la carta
che lui poi c'è non la posso o tutti i
cinque in mano che te lo giuro cercato
rita di pizzerie di scatti non puo
arrivare a uno e non l'ho messa per non
farlo vincere ci pensa te lo avrebbe
vinto se no me lo so ho capito però
mamma mia è opposta 10 basta uno stato
perché basta basta
la prima per 10.000 infarto patom occhio
che pietro st 2 16 a guardare non
guardando la vendetta astro boy
assorbiti in più 2 bravo astro brava
proprio lui che lo sa
guarda la faccia da killer che già
guarda la 1 gioco giro di p2 p2
grazie grazie grazie veramente a me sa
che qui che non è o no ok non è il
viaggio aereo sta quella carta qui mura
non è né ritardi né rossa con la causa
che a prescindere
proprio la rete l'avete lui l'europa
vincere è una furiosa con azionamento la
china non ti ha funzionato per questo
motivo è brutto mondo vi faccio i vostri
partiti che ho sempre porca vacca rega e
sicurezza pescato uniti più quattro
dietro 26 più 4 occhio e comunque ve lo
dico pietro se io non riesco a rubarti
lecca le carte vengono ad aguero ball
monitor a cose a casa ecco per higuain
100 tipi 4 cercare tutti la qualità
quello che ha detto non vuoi giocare
perché avevano potuto in concatenare più
quattro no ma perché non si poteva
concatenare rivamar messa che se lo con
catena se lo canton catena via arrivava
12 sì perché non si può fare
e tu pensi sia finita le ovvero quanti
ne hai dietro però sappi che un 7 in
mano di ogni colore
adesso ti mando una foto squazza pon 7
nostra non trovando perché sono vedi
piumazzo e di ogni colore andargli una
foto del mazzo pezzente un aspetto e non
quelli passo di lettere ma allora va
fatto sentire il traiano per palpabile
propinare mazzo eh sì perché è l'unico
che non capisce quello che guarda quel
pezzo di un robot inutile guarda guarda
come dessert quel più marchio chimica di
posta complimenti complimenti con chi lo
cambi
no ma che chiama che carte avevi le dai
ma quella era diastro le mie sono dei 90
fa cambiare a perché lo zero un cerchio
è se cambiamo è la strada migliore
io le cambiano solo con lui c'era
cambieremo solo noi due praticamente ha
già è vero spetta ma adesso a ruolo con
le pesca 21 giocherà uno in questo
momento posso decidere chi vince e chi
perde
no non cambiare le carte non cambiare le
carte in coda al più 4 no no io niente
non posso vincere perché arrivano
recensione attenzione attenzione dai
astro lavori cotta ma sai che io ho
sempre voluto quel mazzolino ma sono più
quello lì volo ma che cosa dico che a me
piace ancora di più invece combattuto 6
devo ma il comitato tantissimo ma sai
che mazzo bello un casino che poi alla
fine sono tutti lì
no dai ma come tra tutte quelle che non
dovrà avere parola che carta loro euro
le tue mani ora è tutto nelle tue leo
sochi carta viva questa cosa che stai
giocando non l'ha giocata a roma erano
avere sentito in colpissi ma ce l'hai
l'ultima dietro motivi corto vivo è un
gioco il cambio giro mikado sotto
no dai fare tu sei stupido che è pesca
non ce l'hai non c'era non celando cielo
non ce l'ha
uno che io non ce l'hanno già prima non
c'erano anche a destra attenzione voi
non ce l'ho
beh io riprovo scovando sarai ancora
tifare signori la chiude lui del rene è
bellissima bellissima gara è piaciuto un
sacco
ragazzi vi ringrazio
le grazie di cazione euro e pietro
dovete loro grande scrizione ringrazio
soprattutto uno per essere un gioco così
bello che mi fa odiare i miei amici non
scherza solo i robot è piaciuto iscritte
via canale lasciate il tasto lasciate un
commento non il tasto lasciate anche un
tasto se volete nei commenti piace il
tasto mi piace e la campanella che è
utilissima per che suona ed è bella e
noi ci diamo seguito ai ragazzi
[Musica]